serge fiori bonjour 11 ont commencé
cette aventure un peu folle de cirque
éloize kivu ils vont monter votre vie
musicale finalement voix m'a vu à tout
niveau bas c'est un mystère règne sur
quinze ans que je rêvais de me marier
même ce gain du cirque le cirque éloize
et mon site préféré j'ai vu leurs shows
the tiger par ge et aux sacs assez malin
pour its rameaux et de secteurs pire
qu'une bonne âme amusé coup je rêvasse
j'ai apparemment j'ai apparemment jamais
certain demande intérieure savoir et
vous ça arrivera pomme et bien flou
l'appel
ok on palpe utero navire encore jeannot
painchaud
le président se met à parler enfin que
cergy le moment j'ai eu 70 heures pour
qu'un échange elle sort jury si chalon
organise un quine mon passage terminator
le téléphone sonne
et ça c'est ya combien de time un art
donc ça se touche à ses fins a su la
folie c'est bien beau mais là c'est
qu'un moyen c'est comme si je me
souviens d'en faire les premières clés
lui ce matériel que peut-être j'aimerais
si gm system move elle c'est effrayant
je l'écouté sont stables mais je n'ai
pas fait beaucoup d'affaires m'envahit
notamment vu dans son lancement comme ça
marche à portneuf anton a feint pilot
bike en même temps au pense à caen mâcon
faso avec qui sait quoi qu'on cherche
c'est qu'on a des marches
tu ne penses
un des réalisateurs on pense à nogent
cornu qui lui est avec alex mcmahon est
mauvais le bouvillon guillaume chartrain
qu'il en soit je regarde de son musicien
vous êtes avec avec louis jean donc il
ya une filiation mais stocker quinzistes
de craon ces rencontres réussies
ça a pris 5 sa gare de louvain zup on
est parti ça arrive ça mais ma faim on
en fera voir même place on vient la même
place
c'était hallucinant la provenance parler
cela comme bloquer ces belles dames et
là il m'a présenté des excuses a intégré
en sont devenus carrément mes gars et
moi je suis pas gros mais calais c'est
comme si un enfant mais c'est la vue
c'est un bon garçon alex et le manga
sont jaloux gens c'est juste en sorte
que c'est réglé c'est comme et là on
rentre à la première station pause on
reçoit plein temps contre les spams et
thomas shine gauche et on n'a rien mais
ça joue ça ça ils ravissent à savoir
même plus ce qu'est ce que ça ajoutant
va en vente en guillaume des dix
extraits qu'est-ce que d'abord c'est
quoi votre objectif de prendre ces
pièces là qui sont pour la plupart des
bijoux quand même mais de les
transformer pour aller où
pour faire quoi mais un peu pour pour en
fait pour respecter le
des cierges et l'harmonium mais pour
aller où scientix était seul objectif
que ça je voulais si on avait la chance
de l'avoir avec nous en profiterons
s'arrêter d'un trop de projets de ports
au siège de d'abord sèche qui traitait
avec nous du début à la fin puis comme
acquis moi je change mon oeuvre pour
aller le même si ce test un peu plus à
chaque fois de nous fait nous écouter un
exemple de la chambre au salon de votre
premier harmonia je vous ai détesté
d'abord parce que je la jouais live tout
seul c'est un style jack ma guitare m
avoue à la catastrophe c'est un monde de
voile est passée la chanter pour
quelqu'un de normal soit un passage des
sacs poubelles enfin quand j'ai fait mes
premiers plessisville et on se détourne
pas taillé depuis avec des poubelles
puis elle est à la parade un coup droit
je vais avec plus rien sans les manger
un bébé ou la chambre où ça ne
m'intéresse pas là c'est parti on va est
revenue est revenue voulez vous
l'écoutez en fait l'origine à huy
envoyer un petit bout de région je garde
mes idées je dis je
on est
sonné
a part ça la ne croit je regarde mes
idées je les jours à courant vont
compter pour tenir la chandelle
la même prise de voix avec elle en
voyant la foulée coeur 90
car belle madame il s'appelle la
mainmise offspring kabel madame
installés le long des bandes
ça donne mais sauf que à menu de ces
instruments
mais le quatuor à cordes et la voix qui
porte à nos places
tout change il y de los teques sparano
tout change
il va avoir cinq robes haka la danse la
magie le rêve du cirque chercheurs sur
ce je vous l'avais jamais vu encore ce
pratiquant le justement c'était coeur
c'est qu'avant parce que c'est un
serpent la thématique de quand tu vis
des ruptures ou une rupture puissantes
ont entamé raison la chambre salon ça
d'années je te compliquer pts a rompu
churchill man qui je suis bon je suis là
d'un paquet coq qui sont dans un espèce
de tourbillon s'attirer qui sort pouces
qui reviennent me fait marrer est ce
qu'il ya des voix que vous avez refaite
complètement plein pour lesquels une
telle taxe si bien de mon environnement
ok avec le même quatuor à cordes et qui
je voulais vraiment aller dans une
fragilité par rapport à ce ton par
rapport à la version geof ça ça c'est
fait je me suis allé je sais que
guillaume et lundi
maman ma g class vraiment je suis bien
content
salam salam olam et haoussa et demi
avant est ce que vous tapez entre
guillemets plus que quand vous avez fait
l'état d'où quand vous avez fait et si
la 25e saison ou sur wii et que sais je
peux pas
quand j'ai fait la pta la maison cinq
saisons là bas avec louis gallois qui
toujours mon droit maintenant ceux qui
en avaient bien été hallucinant
extraordinaire peut pas vivre ce départ
à 10 heures c'est l'extase zénith mais
je pense à pau revivre une expérience où
la mort dans ce projet par une lamelle
koch mfwa débat parce que moi je parle
même box s'est moqué par ailleurs c'est
vrai mais je suis bien je lui sers un
point beaucoup plus donc je le suis
c'est que l'amour c'est un créativité
c'est pour joindre que la banale des
garçons on arrive là soit je prends mon
whisky à 8 ans maintenant les gens sont
les textos s'est pas déjà tout le monde
juge breuil que les échos que j'ai eus
de ces trois là c'est effectivement
qu'il ya une soudure il ya une mènera
campagne rations qui avait opéré timing
je pense qui est là aussi comme camille
lui détailler le pour acquérir ce qui
nous on est au moment où dans nos
carrières on y lit on
aupic l'un peut pour l'heure à savoir
qui le gênait risque lui entend aussi
après la pause serge fiori on va écouter
un petit bout de musique après la peau
je vous parlais de l'avenir après ça ce
qu'on peut qu'est ce qu'on fait en fait
qu'on retombe sur terre d'entre eux mais
si je t'offre une journée qui n'est plus
cette année
pourrais-tu la tenir
on
il
[Musique]
sortir une autre fois
c'est revisité mais c'est pas dénaturer
du tout l'avion on est dans le monde on
est dans votre univers propos de kim et
plus atone va continuer
enfin à tourner à gauche il ya ce peut
pas dénaturer chanson ça fait passer de
ces crus sauf que d'aller de l'avant par
exemple on peut c'est ça qu'on a fait
c'est comme les boubli bout on explorait
musicalement des affaires d'un site
brasse le petit mason à 20 mètres chacun
d'un autre côté est ce que c'est
vraiment ça va tourner et on sait pas
combien de temps à montréal ce québec
vous des blues allaient être là tous les
soirs à l'aidant à cacher dans la salle
je penserais pas vers le tube non non à
l'ugta le show commence au sein des
mouches classique je regarde le
précieusement et s'est fait que ces
poissons
enfin que l'on s'y trouvait à ce terrain
à côté de 5 me c'est dingue ça bien trop
vus tous en vie ce n'est qu'une scénique
en 3e place devant nous arranger ce
polar de t'choupi c'est pas un hasard si
cette voie ce building l'aude de la
clope en soirée tout et toute la musique
qu'ils étaient faits à l'arrivée il ne
changera pas le micro et le monde c'est
celle qui tu vois les gens le monde pour
qui tu fais ce qui te soit cette musique
leurs tripes et jouer la dengue points
seulement tribune que ça va apaiser
peut-être l'envi que les gens ont de
vous entendre et entend en spectacle on
vous pose toujours la question parce que
mon aîné vous allez avoir envie de jeu
mêlant vie doit être là mais le goût
mais le désir de le faire vraiment de
monter sur scène avec un concept
je pense enfin fermé josso peau mais je
pense que oui parce que la ligne la
route trace en ce moment vous m'auriez
dit que je refasse projet lgv n'a jamais
procuré ne l'a pas cru la la clarté puis
la concentration d'être capable de faim
puis de l'énergie d'être capable de le
faire donc la route sous jeux comme un
pied n'aura pas accès kamer qui
ramassent à peu ce pas j'ai aucune idée
parce que chi
avec vos trois fils ou avec donc pas
tant que ça vous tente
c'est probable bruce les garçons
pourquoi pas ça tu vas entrer dans vos
ça sera un an
c'est sûr qu'on aimerait enfin
s'affrontent au pull et un album avec
des nouvelles takka takka lui
sauf que chaque sont rapidement
c'est une course nature mais pas ce mot
les clés dessus ça vient d'un coup c'est
un peu ça comme un compliment enfin
parce que ça a été compliqué c'est pour
ça que c'est si l'une est que si notre
affaire non mais pour vrai cette
relation là ya pas beaucoup de gens
qu'ils ont avec le public avec les
émotions du public le volant une mouche
je suis assommé fait belge aujourd'hui
je regarde la réaction des gens qui se
sont touchés
je suis à 100 c'est très dur pour modèle
vivant même temps on achève cac lâché
j'ai le foil jeunes tristesse mais ça va
être le prochain projet wesh bien on a
on a très très voir sur scène au st
denis donc ça commence ce soir à québec
après peu merci infiniment merci
beaucoup merci
puis on continue de la maison merci
sergerie merci beaucoup bien merci
beaucoup merci